des français qui sont dont on pourra en
croire les sondages évidemment la
création de ce passeport vaccinale alors
que le gouvernement lui est contre on en
parle ce matin avec notre reporter
nadège abderrazak
[Musique]
bonjour nadège alors on en parlait à
l'instant avec alexis poulain le
passeport bah c'est pas gagné d'avancé
c'est vrai même si les français semblent
prêtes à tout pour retrouver une vie
normale alors d'après un sondage du
parisien ils seraient majoritairement
favorables à la mise en place d'un
passeport sanitaire contre le coc vide
c'est à dire un certificat de
vaccination attestant qu'ils sont
immunisés pour se rendre sur certains
lieux réalisé certaines activités comme
par exemple aller au théâtre au cinéma
ou dans une salle de sport il serait
précisément 60 2% à se prononcer en
faveur de la vaccination obligatoire
pour ceux qui souhaitent se rendre à
l'étranger par avion par exemple un
passeport sanitaires pour le
gouvernement c'est non en tout cas pour
l'instant réticence est un débat qui n'a
pas lieu d'être et ce serait choquant
alors qu'on débute encore partout cette
campagne de vaccination en europe qu'il
y a des droits plus important pour
certains que pour d'autres ce n'est pas
notre conception de la protection et de
l'accès au vaccin
un passeport sanitaire ce n'est pas une
idée nouvelle puisque la proposition a
été sous-entendu la fin décembre lors de
la présentation du projet de loi sur les
urgences sanitaires
le premier ministre peut subordonner les
déplacements des personnes leur accès
aux moyens de transport ou à certains
lieux ainsi que l'exercice de certaines
activités à la présentation des
résultats d'un test de dépistage
établissant que la personne n'est pas
affecté ou contaminés au suivi d'un
traitement préventif y compris à
l'administration d'un vaccin ou d'un
traitement curatif et la dèche face aux
critiques le gouvernement a rapidement
revu sa copie la supprimer le texte en
question le plan européen au niveau
européen en tout cas on prend très au
sérieux cette idée de passeports
sanitaire le sujet à d'abord été évoquée
par la grèce la grèce qui est bien a vu
l'une des principales sources de revenus
le tourisme s'effondrer à cause de la
pandémie de
comme il 19 le pays à lui sur le plan
national déjà une mise en place un
certificat destinée à prouver que l'on a
été déçu que l'on a été vaccinée contre
le commis 19 mattel et bien souhaiterait
étendre cette mesure à l'ensemble des 27
pays membres de l'union européenne
les personnes vaccinées doivent être
libres de voyager
il est urgent d'élaborer un accord
commun sur la création d'un certificat
de vaccination qui sera acceptée par
tous les pays membres
le passeport vaccinale solution pour
mettre un terme à l'épidémie de comics
19 que la mesure soit efficace ou non
elle pourrait en tout cas accroître les
inégalités entre entre les pays
fin décembre amnesty international est
une coalition d'organisations évalué que
dans l'état actuel des choses dans 70
pays pauvres seulement un habitant sur
10 pourront être vaccinées d'ici la fin
de l'année un passeport vaccinale
solution miracle ou fausse bonne idée
est la question fait débat et pour cause
à ce jour aucune étude ne dit si les
différents vaccins utilisés actuellement
et bien immunise contre le kobe 19,6
l'empêchent réellement la propagation du
virus
les campagnes de vaccination ayant
débuté que très récemment pour les
premiers pays on n'a pas suffisamment de
recul ni de résultats fiables pour
l'instant
merci beaucoup nadège pour toutes ces
précisions concernant le passeport
vaccinale pour voyager